hi I'm Bruce Willis I'm about to do the
wired auto-complete interview and
confused by this which is why I don't go
on internet very often does Bruce Willis
sing sadly he does in some secluded
rendezvous does Bruce Willis have an
album yes the return of Bruno does Bruce
Willis have a Twitter account I don't
understand Twitter so does Bruce Willis
say yippie ki-yay yes he does from time
to time and he flies these across the
room what is Bruce Willis tattoo it
would have to be tattoos
some animals my wife's name what is
Bruce Wallace known for violence
laughter and looper what is Bruce
Willis's address I'm not gonna tell you
my address
what is Bruce Willis's phone number
Bruce will it's it's hard to say my last
name want that phone number it'll be on
that card
what's bruce willis real name walter
bruce willis bruce willis what was bruce
willis his first movie the first deadly
sin with Frank Sinatra I was a stand-in
for David dukes
what does Bruce Willis say at the end of
Armageddon what did I say at the end we
win Gracie
what does Bruce Willis drive about 240
you know if it's not raining drive so
what does Bruce Willis look like this is
it I think you got it was Bruce Willis
Batman that mask was real sweaty was
Bruce clothes at Woodstock
tried to get to it never got in the mud
was Bruce Willis a dancer no was Bruce
Willis in the military tried to get in I
was a little too old and is
is Bruce Willis German I was born in
Germany and then I moved to New Jersey
is Bruce Willis from Philadelphia
no wanted to be from Philadelphia Bruce
Willis is is Bruce Willis the clown in
Uncle Buck is Bruce Willis thanos
similar look and if I ever meet
Thanos I'm gonna be very nice with is
Bruce Willis alive yes did Bruce Willis
go to college yes
Montclair State College did Bruce Willis
appear in friends I was on friends
because I lost a bet to Matthew Perry
did Bruce Willis won an Oscar no I did
get two Golden Globes and an Emmy how
did Bruce Willis meet Emma Heming Gunnar
Peterson and induced me to Emma we are
still married and happy and happy about
it